ahora ya sabemos cómo calcular el
coeficiente de precio por ganancias
vamos a ver si podemos utilizarlo para
hacer un juicio acerca de si una
compañía es barata o si es caja
comparada con otra compañía entonces
supongamos que tenemos la compañía y la
compañía ve y pues nada más para ser un
poco más precisos con la discusión vamos
a pensar que estas dos compañías son de
la misma industria
esto es importante tenemos que comparar
manzanas con manzanas porque en la vida
real es muy diferente comparar
coeficientes pp de empresas que se
dedican a distintas cosas después vamos
a hablar un poco más de por qué pasa eso
pero ahorita simplemente vamos a pensar
que son compañías de software entonces
supongamos que la compañía a cada acción
o sea el precio por acción de la
compañía es de 10 pesos y acá en la
compañía de supongamos que su precio por
acción es de 20 pesos
entonces recuerda únicamente la
información del precio no me dice que es
barata es cara
solo aprendimos en el primer vídeo
entonces ahora digamos que sus ganancias
en 2008 las ganancias de 2008
para la compañía fueron de un peso un
peso por acción un peso gpa estoy aquí
es jefe a verdad no es ganancias totales
el gpa para encontrar las ganancias
totales hay que multiplicar esto por el
número de acciones y para la compañía ve
digamos que es 5 pesos 5 pesos por
acción
gp
muy bien entonces cuáles son sus
coeficientes de precio por ganancias sus
coeficientes p
a ver en la compañía a es 10 verdad el
precio es 10 dividido entre 110 y acá
abajo la compañía ve es 20 el precio es
20 las ganancias por acción es 520 entre
5 es 4 ok entonces acá abajo es 4 pues
simplemente cuando vemos
superficialmente esta información si
vemos el precio por ganancia y bueno
esto es un pequeño paréntesis cuando
alguien te dice que el precio por
ganancias es tanto es 10 o es 4 la
primera cosa de la cual tienes que
asegurarte es de qué tipo de ganancias
están hablando si son las ganancias
históricas las ganancias de los últimos
12 meses o si son las ganancias forwards
las ganancias que se predijeron en este
caso son las del año pasado verdad las
del 2008 eres una cosa muy importante de
la cual nos tenemos que acordar pero
bueno basado en las ganancias de 2008
aquí tenemos un 10 y aquí tenemos un 4
coeficientes de precio por ganancias
entonces por cada peso verdad por cada
peso de ganancias por año si crees que
las ganancias son esto estás pagando 4
pesos abajo y arriba por cada peso que
ganas estás pagando 10 pesos entonces
abajo parece ser que es más barato
verdad parece que la compañía ve es más
barata mientras menor sea el precio por
ganancias entonces quiere decir que es
más barato comprar eso porque por la
misma cantidad de ganancias le estás
pagando menos arriba estás pagando 10 y
abajo estás pagando 4
entonces parece ser que la compañía ve
es más barata y mira si todo fuera igual
si estas dos compañías fueran idénticas
en términos de su estructura de capital
de la deuda que tienen de su razón de
crecimiento de su riesgo también del
mercado en el que operan de sus clientes
y pues incluso de su ventaja competitiva
si todas estas cosas fueran igualitas
entonces estaríamos en lo correcto
en efecto estaríamos en lo correcto de
que sería una compañía más barata que ha
y observa esto es justo lo opuesto de lo
que se ve por fuera con el precio verdad
aquí vez se ve más caro pero acabe
más barato ok entonces inmediatamente
así verás esto en el mercado real que
hay dos compañías idénticas y una está
cotizada más barata que la otra o bueno
tiene un precio por ganancia más bajo
que el otro entonces deberías de
sospechar muchísimo hay una pequeña
posibilidad de que sea la primera
persona en ver eso pero bueno en este
caso si deberías pues comprar muchas
acciones debe vender muchas a que desde
ahí podrías ganar mucho dinero pero
deberías de sospechar mucho porque es
como el chiste clásico de los dos
economistas que van caminando por la
calle y se encuentran con un billete de
200 pesos 200 pesos entonces uno dice
oye por qué no levantamos ese billete y
el otro dice no no que acaso no merece
economista claramente no puede ser un
billete de 200 porque si lo fuera
alguien más ya lo hubiera agarrado
jajaja bueno la elección es que el
mercado no permite que haya dinero
gratis tirado por ahí si tuviéramos el
caso de estas dos compañías entonces
esta discrepancia básicamente sería
dinero gratis tirado por ahí la primera
persona en verlo compraría muchas
acciones de hebe y entonces subiría su
precio luego se vendería mucho a bajaría
su precio y con eso el mercado equilibra
de ambas va entonces el precio por
ganancia de estas dos compañías debería
ser igual siempre y cuando y esto es
decir mucho estas dos compañías
realmente fueran equivalentes otra vez
por la ley de la oferta y la demanda
pero déjame hacerte una pregunta
supongamos que no sabemos que realmente
son iguales porque alguien estaría
dispuesto o sea porque pagaría un precio
por ganancias de 10 por la compañía a ya
cambio dejar pasar la oportunidad o
bueno simplemente no querer comprar en
vez de donde tienen un precio por
ganancia de 4 que es más barato vaya
porque querer pagar 10 pesos por cada
peso de ganancias según 2008
en vez de pagar 4 pesos de la compañía
ve por cada peso de ganancia en 2008
bueno ya habíamos platicado un poco
acerca de eso a lo mejor la compañía es
súper segura casi como una cuenta de
banco y la compañía ve pues y a lo mejor
hizo 25 pesos por acción este año pero
puede ser muy riesgoso no sé a lo mejor
la compañía de este año ganó cinco pesos
por acción pero el siguiente pues puede
perderlos la compañía es mucho más
estable
otra razón es que aquí solo son las
ganancias de 2008 pero un año de
ganancias
realmente no refleja qué le sucede a una
compañía una compañía puede tiene muy
bien un año muy mal el otro podría
crecer que puede hacerse más chiquita y
esa es la cosa importante pues ya
siempre está esta tentación cuando
inviertes de veras que tras ver qué le
sucedió a las acciones en el pasado o
sea cuánto gana una compañía en el
pasado cuando creció pero todo eso es
irrelevante todo eso ya está en el
precio de la acción eso ya sucedió y
cualquier dinero que se tuvo que haber
ganado ya se ganó siempre tienes que ver
a futuro entonces supongamos que esto de
aquí son las ganancias de 2008 pero
pasemos ahora a las de 2009 y supongamos
que se vea algo diferente entonces
pasamos a 2009 y entonces en 2009 el gpa
aquí está aquí está bien entonces a se
espera que va a ganar 22 pesos por
acción va a ganar 2 pesos por acción y
ve supongamos que se espera que va a
ganar que va a seguir ganando no mejor
que gana 4 pesos por acción
entonces ahora si calculamos el
coeficiente p para las ganancias de 2009
supongamos por el momento que no se ha
acabado 2009 no sé por ejemplo que
estamos grabando esto en agosto de 2009
entonces este número pues no sería así
un dato duro sea pensando en que todavía
no ha acabado 2009 pues muchas personas
inteligentes tienen que llegar a un
estimado o sea una proyección de las
ganancias digo de las ganancias por
acción bueno por acá el precio el precio
por ganancias para 2009 es déjame ver a
ver estamos pagando diez pesos por dos
pesos de ganancia en 2009 y entonces el
precio por ganancias es de 5 para la
compañía a verdad y para la compañía de
su precio por ganancias es 20 entre 4
que también es 5 entonces observa con el
precio por ganancias de 2009 se ven muy
similares aunque viendo hacia atrás la
compañía se veía más cara tenía un
precio por ganancias más alto pero ahora
cuando vemos las ganancias de 2009 se
ven muy similares
entonces la pregunta era por qué alguien
pagaría más por la compañía
bueno pues una de las razones es esto
que acabamos de ver ahora cuando vemos
el 2009 se ven tus casi iguales vaya con
el paso del tiempo el precio por
ganancias en nivela y entonces estás
pagando cinco pesos por lo mismo pero
observa la tendencia la compañía empezó
ganando un peso pero luego ganó dos
pesos en 2009 entonces pues a lo mejor
hay algunos estimados para el siguiente
año para 2010 oa lo mejor puedes hacer
tu propio estimado de 2010 y creer que
esta compañía la compañía tiene un
producto muy súper bueno súper caro está
creciendo y en 2010 va a ser dos pesos
con cincuenta centavos va a crecer otro
25 por ciento en 2010 entonces a lo
mejor creció menos pero igual creció por
otro lado la compañía de paso de cinco
pesos de gpa a cuatro pesos de gpa en
2009 y no sé tal vez esta disminución
continua en el futuro y para 2010 nada
más hace dos pesos por acción que sucede
ahora si hacemos un coeficiente pp para
2010 a 2010 pues es dos años después de
que empezaron las compañías entonces
este coeficiente pp para 2010 de repente
pasa
pero en términos de las proyecciones de
ganancias para 2010 4 para la compañía
10 para la compañía ve entonces ahora
intercambiamos lugares verdad la
compañía ve ahora se ve más cara en 2010
con las ganancias de 2010 y la compañía
se ve súper barata y esto es una cosa
muy importante en un período actual o
sea en este momento puede ser que estés
dispuesto a pagar un mayor precio por
ganancias y la compañía está creciendo y
un menor precio por ganancia si la
compañía no está creciendo entonces
crecimiento es una de las razones por
las cuales pagaría su mayor precio por
ganancia un buen ejercicio déjame
hacerlo por acá arriba a lo mejor
alguien podría ver una compañía digamos
que se llamase que está cotizando se en
100 pesos se está cotizando en 100 pesos
y supongamos que para 2009 la gente
espera que la compañía se va a ganar
digamos un peso por acción
todas muchísimas personas inmediatamente
encontrarían el precio por ganancias
basado en el estimado de las ganancias
de 2009 y recuerda que es súper
importante recordar si las ganancias son
estimados o pasadas ok bueno aquí es el
pronóstico para 2009 y tiene un p de 100
uf eso está loquísimo yo jamás compraría
algo tan caro
quizás debería empezar a venderlo pero
ojo eso podría ser algo tonto si no eres
cuidadoso puedes decir no no no haber
momento no lo vendas piénsalo tantito
esta compañía está creciendo tan rápido
que no es buena idea vender sus acciones
basado en mis predicciones y acaban de
pegar en el punto clave al mercado
tienen una propiedad intelectual súper
buena en 2010 se espera que esta
compañía duplique sus ganancias por
acción que es más que se duplique cada
año por los siguientes tres años bueno
va ok entonces en 2010 va a ganar dos
pesos dos pesos por acción el pp sigue
siendo bueno en 2010 2010 el pp sería de
100 entre 1250 50 es como no sigue
siendo muy caro es mucho más caro que
casi todas las compañías del precio por
ganancia en el mercado es como 17 o 18
porque pagaría 50 veces las ganancias es
muchísimo y más aún además ahora sabes
que si viste el vídeo de valor presente
el dinero en el futuro vale menos que el
dinero ahorita pero decimos no sabes que
estos están creciendo tan rápido que
para 2011 también se van a duplicar van
a ganar 4 pesos por acción de repente
por ganancias se ve mucho mejor ahora es
de 25 y luego podrías decir no sólo eso
sino que en 2012 estoy segurísimo de que
acaban de darle a 100 el punto clave y
van a ser 8 pesos por acción
se siguen duplicando pues hasta 2012 de
repente baja a 12.5 el precio por
ganancia entonces pues si este
crecimiento siguiera y esto es
importante verdad el crecimiento tiene
que seguir y seguir no puedes
simplemente pagar un precio de 100 por
un año verdad y eso está muy mal si
crees en un crecimiento de 100 por
ciento nada más por un año entonces pues
no está padre acabar con un pd de 50 es
algo muy caro por otro lado si si sigue
creciendo y creciendo no sé 100% por
cinco años entonces se empieza a sonar
un poco más interesante en 2013 estarían
ganando 16 pesos por acción y el
coeficiente de precios por ganancias se
hace 6.25 baratísimo
y entonces en el debate de si estás
dispuesto a pagar un precio por ganancia
muy alto en este caso un precio por
ganancia de 100 mucha gente la verdad no
se anima se le va a hacer algo súper
caro piensa que el mercado está loco y
se preguntaría por qué alguien lo
compraría bueno pues la razón por la
cual lo pagarían y suponiendo que no
están especulando y casi nadie en el
mercado lo está es que creen que la
compañía está creciendo muy rápido y no
sólo eso sino que va a crecer por un
largo periodo de tiempo y esto de largo
periodo es importante es realmente la
compañía tiene que crecer bien por
muchos muchos años en este ejemplo 5 ó 6
años está bien este precio por acción
que paga este al principio de 100 ya no
se ve tan alocado por una compañía que
crece al cien por ciento por cinco o
seis años pero si creciera al cien por
ciento por 20 años uff sería un
negociazo claro obviamente un
coeficiente de precio por ganancia de 6
en 2013 pues no es tan bueno como un
coeficiente por ganancia de 6 en
términos de 2010 porque pues las
ganancias en el futuro
no valen tanto como ganancias en este
año eso lo puedes verificar en el vídeo
de valor presente pero un crecimiento de
100 por ciento es mucho mejor que casi
cualquier tasa de descuento sale
entonces esta es una buena forma de
pensar
la razón por la cual estaría dispuesto a
pagar un precio por ganancias más alto
es por crecimiento y más aún por
crecimiento que si creas realmente que
va a continuar y continuar ok entonces
la otra razón es que piensas que hay un
riesgo muy bajo en cierta compañía eso
ya lo platicamos en el vídeo pasado de
hecho creo que el precio era 50 para una
cuenta bancaria verdad en fin nada más
déjame platicarte un último punto
ahorita que ya estamos cerca del final
del vídeo es un poco técnico es una
regla de cabecera en la cual la gente
dice que si una compañía no está
creciendo mucho es estable tampoco se
está haciendo más chiquita entonces un
precio por ganancias son coeficiente p
justo o barato es de 10 o sea que la
acción cueste 10 veces las ganancias por
acción y claro aquí tienes todo el
derecho de preguntarme de dónde viene
esto porque no es 9 o porque no es 12 y
de hecho es una muy buena pregunta no
hay una razón obvia por la cual no sea 9
o 12 lo que puedo decir es que es 10
número 1 porque es un bonito número
cerrado y número 2
mira si tuviéramos una racha de
ganancias de la siguiente forma
2009-2010
2011 en todos los años 2012 y así
sucesivamente si todos los años tenemos
una racha de digamos un peso de
ganancias y trajéramos esto a valor
presente utilizando una tasa de
descuento a lo mejor deberías ver el
vídeo de valor presente si esto te
confunde pero bueno si trajera valor
presente estas ganancias que siguen y
siguen indefinidamente jaja si
trajéramos a valor presente todas estas
ganancias entonces como imaginamos que
estamos en 2009 un peso sería un peso un
peso de 2010 hay que dividirlo entre la
tasa de descuento digamos que estamos
usando una tasa de descuento del 11% en
la vida real si es como es ahorita nomás
estamos como aproximando le pero bueno
entonces el valor de ese peso sería un
peso dividido entre 1.11 verdad nada más
dividido entre el 1% aquí sería uno
entre 1.11 elevado al cuadrado acá sería
uno entre 1.11 elevado al cubo y si
sumar a todo esto si hicieras la serie
geométrica entonces obtendrías
aproximadamente 10 bueno 10 veces estas
ganancias aquí es un peso de 3 obtendrás
aquí es de donde viene la regla es decir
en vez de todos los días hacer las
cuentas para jalar los números a valor
presente y pues poder tener muchos
errores
se inventó una regla sencilla de
cabecera que claro hay que ajustar según
varía la tasa de interés y otros
factores de riesgo ahorita no me quiero
meter en muchos detalles nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo